blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman well my friends they are
putting the people who incited the
january sixth trump riots in charge of
the investigation into what happened on
january 6th yes there's going to be a
january 6 commission
but much the same way that donald trump
wanted
his own lawyers
investigating what happened and telling
legislators what happened with the
election i need 11 000 votes give me a
break exactly they are going to put in
some of the very republicans whose
denial of the election results and
rhetoric
fomented those very riots which they
will now be in investigating this is
like what putting o.j simpson in charge
of what happened to nicole brown simpson
this is like putting
take your pick i mean it's just a wealth
of analogies and and metaphors and none
of it makes any sense but the goals of
kevin mccarthy the house minority leader
in choosing the people that he chose for
this are very very clear esquire has a
nice article by charlie pierce about
this
called kevin mccarthy is stacking the
january 6th commission
with big lie advocates just
dumping in
dumps the very people who fomented these
riots to begin with let's read
this commission while certainly better
than nothing is doomed to sink beneath
the weight of congressional inertia
uh charlie writes i am perhaps not wise
in the ways of washington but i fail to
see what sense it makes to allow members
of congress who have demonstrated their
allegiance to the gross untruth that was
at the root of all the violence onto the
special commission tasked with
investigating the january sixth
insurrection
uh quoting from the washington post that
kevin mccarthy has selected listen to
this
congressman jim jordan from ohio and jim
banks from indiana two
massive big lie perpetuators as well as
rodney davis
kelly armstrong and troy nels
the lawmakers met with mccarthy on
monday banks said that he has accepted
mccarthy's invitation
to serve as the top republican on the
panel quote because we need leaders who
will force the democrats and the media
to answer questions so far ignored
i hope you guys know what that means
like i hope you understand that the
point of selecting these people
in particular banks and especially jim
jim jordan
uh is they aren't going to be going in
with the perspective of wow
there was violence who caused it and
let's hold those people accountable
that's what that's what would make sense
they're going to go in with the
perspective of wow there was some
violence
and it was warranted because the
election was stolen and there was every
reason to believe that donald trump may
have been the rightful winner of that
election this is how backwards this
commission is going to be so the
position we're now in is one of having
to ask well okay so
republicans
number one
who are investigating quote
investigating
are perpetuators they should be
witnesses rather than uh investigators
but number two
they're not really even going to
investigate they're going to try to
perpetuate the big lie as a
justification for what took place these
people were angry and okay some
committed crimes and the court system
will deal with that but these people
were rightly angry
because it does appear as though there
was funny business here and there was
funny business there and we had all the
reasons to believe that the election may
not have been done the way it should
have been done that's what they're going
to do
so then the question is well is it worth
is it a net gain to do it at all
given that democrats will have their
opportunity
to to show the the the violence and all
of the other stuff i actually question
it i actually question it because the
people who are going to
fall for
the republican approach to this
committee to this commission
um aren't even going to listen to what
the democrats have to say and i really
question
what is going to productively come out
of this i'm not sure if it's a net gain
quite frankly uh let's look look at a
little bit more here
among the five white men selected by
mccarthy
three of them voted against certifying
the current president's victory all of
them voted against impeaching
uh trump for his role in inciting the
violence that descended upon the capital
to be entirely fair nails a former
sheriff apparently was of invaluable
assistance to the capitol police when
the when congress was under siege
of course
uh
tiger beat on the potomac has found the
proper euphemisms while the california
republican took his time deciding
between naming more experienced members
to the probe
filling his seats with firebrands and
refusing to tap any members at all
mccarthy mccarthy ultimately chose to go
with the former route with his
selections his his picks have the
committee leadership and oversight chops
to counter democrats who are expected to
use the select panel to hammer trump and
the republican party for fueling the
deadly assault on the capital in which
jim jordan is no longer a firebrand if
he takes this as an attack on his
previous four years of service he might
burn the capital down so this is going
to be an absolute gong show we may cover
some or much of it or maybe none of it
live i'm not sure exactly what we're
going to do yet but if you were
expecting that aha moment
maybe a come to jesus moment for lack of
a better term
where republicans the vast majority will
say wow trump really had a lot to do
with what happened on january 6th
um no that's absolutely not going to
happen and what will come of this
remains a real question
in light of the anti-vaccine problem
that we have in the united states which
may well prevent us from really getting
past this pandemic there are now more
and more people calling for
mandatory
that's government mandated vaccination
now i want to be really clear
there is a huge difference between
required to do something and straight up
compelled vaccination in other words
we've had for a long time vaccines that
are required if you want
to go to a certain college to send your
kid to a certain school to work in
certain places that wouldn't be new
what people are now actually talking
about more seriously some people it's
not predominant
is the idea of government actually
mandating that people must be vaccinated
period you have to just get the vaccine
a government-mandated vaccine there's an
op-ed in the washington post by max boot
who some people hate called stop
pleading with anti-vaxxers and start
mandating vaccinations now there are
really two parts here first of all is
the question of would a mandatory
vaccine be legal now as a federal
government mandate uh there does not
appear to be precedent for that that you
know it sometimes when we talk about
whether something would be legal
the the language should not be it
doesn't seem like it would be legal but
rather
we're not able to find precedent that
that would be legal at the state level
the answer appears to be that yes state
government in many states could mandate
vaccination you look at jacobson v
massachusetts from 1905
that was a supreme court case in which
the court upheld
the authority of states to enforce
compulsory vaccination laws
the court at the time articulated the
view that individual liberty is not
absolute and is subject to the police
power of the state quote massachusetts
was one of only 11 states that had
compulsory vaccination laws
massachusetts law empowered the board of
health of individual cities and towns to
enforce mandatory free vaccinations for
adults over age 21 if the municipality
determined it was necessary for the
public health or safety of the community
if you refused you had to pay a five
dollar fine in 1902 faced with the
outbreak of smallpox the board of health
of the city of cambridge adopted a
regulation ordering the vaccination or
re-vaccination of inhabitants basically
pointing out that
this is part of preserving liberty when
there is a public health imperative so
legally
it's certainly conceivable that states
which wanted to make the covet vaccine
mandatory could do it then you would get
into questions like does it apply
to people who are legally residents of
the state what if you're traveling
through what if you're temporarily
working in a particular state there's a
ton of complexity that's not really the
issue for me
i am not actively for
mandatory vaccination i'm for informing
people
and encouraging vaccination in other
ways
but it would be political suicide to try
to make the covet vaccine mandatory many
of the people who don't want to get
vaccinated really don't want to get
vaccinated and i believe it would be
unmitigated political disaster for
anyone who tries to push mandatory
vaccination now one other thing
in terms of the current supreme court
my guess is
that the current court
would only go with the precedent of
states being able to mandate vaccination
if and when these vaccines are fully
approved by the fda my instinct is that
if a state tried to do this and there
was a lawsuit and an appeal and an
appeal and it eventually got to the
supreme court that the supreme court is
not going to uphold the precedent when
it comes to
an emergency use authorization i i just
don't imagine that one idea i had which
i tweeted about was this is now other
ways to get people vaccinated i tweeted
if a rumor started that liberals want to
keep the vaccine away from conservatives
so that they die
would it make them get vaccinated to own
the libs this is really childish reverse
psychology but at the same time
it's this type of thing that seems far
more plausible and maybe even more
effective than a government mandated
vaccination i would be curious to hear
from you we've been talking about
this week what if the the vaccines were
marketed
as the trump vaccine as trump juice
uh as a freedom vaccine or whatever the
case may be
would that maybe get some of these
people to go out and get vaccinated when
it comes to mandatory vaccinations even
if you can find legal precedent for it i
don't think it's the way to go in
particular because the backlash and
people who figure out a way to avoid it
anyway and the potential uh politically
suicidal aspect of it it doesn't seem
like the way to go i want to hear from
you though you can find me on twitter at
deepakman and let me know your thoughts
and also we are approaching the 16th
anniversary of the david pakman show and
to celebrate that we will be doing a
one-day membership special on monday
august 16th it's not this month i got an
email yesterday from someone saying
david sir congratulations on 16 years
i'm sorry i'm a few days late they were
actually a month early it is august 16th
technically the 17th
but 16th at midnight anyway you know how
these things go we will be doing a huge
email blast on the 16th telling you how
to take advantage of just an
unconscionable membership discount be
notified
by getting on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video remember that the
david pakman show is mostly sponsored
and made possible by folks like you
people who sign up at joinpacman.com we
do a daily extra show every day we're
done with the show we're toiling under
the hot lights for hours and we do the
show and then it's done
and then we say this can't be it
we must do more and then we do an entire
additional show for our members so i
invite you to sign up at joinpakman.com
one of the most um
sort of mask off moments
literally and metaphorically through the
pandemic about the american right wing
has been the viciousness
with which the right has attacked
medical professionals in general around
the pandemic but in particular the way
dr anthony fauci has been attacked not
only in terms of physical threat to the
point where he needs full-time security
but attacked in terms of his motives
attacked through conspiracies and on and
on and on and one of the main
uh elected officials who has been
attacking dr fauci is senator rand paul
of kentucky who many of you will say
that's dr rand paul sir don't forget
that sir sure yeah but he is an
ophthalmologist um and not an infectious
disease specialist
and he is again tangling up with dr
fauci dr fauci seems to have just had
enough at one point telling uh
rand paul that if anybody's lying it's
him
which we will get to but first saying
that rand paul has no idea what he's
talking about let's look at let's really
look at this first exchange here from
yesterday's hearing and by the way
rand paul seems just obsessed with fauci
it's like groundhog day every single one
of these hearings with these two new
potential pandemic pathogens
potential pandemic pathogens that exist
only in the lab not in nature
this research matches these are dr
ebright's words this research matches
indeed epitomizes the definition of gain
of function research done entirely in
wuhan
for which there was supposed to be a
federal pause
dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress do you wish to retract
your statement of may 11. so already i
mean implying that
that
fauci has perjured himself by lying you
claimed that the nih never funded gain
of function research in wuhan
senator
senator paul i have never lied before
the congress and i do not retract
that statement
this paper that you were referring to
was judged by qualified staff up and
down the chain
as not
being gained
a function
let me finish take an animal virus and
you increase this transability to humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
function yeah that is correct and and
senator paul you do not know what you
are talking about quite frankly and i
want to say that officially you do not
know what you are talking about
okay you get one person from the nih
he's not even allowed to fully answer
the question it's this rand paul is just
some of the worst of the worst of the
american political establishment
function this is your definition that
you guys wrote it says that scientific
research that increases the transmilita
transmissibility among animals is gain
of function they took animal viruses
that only occur in animals and they
increase their transmissibility to
humans how you can say that is not gain
a function it is not it's a dance and
you're dancing around this because
you're trying to obscure responsibility
for four million people dying around the
world from a pandemic and let's let's
send doctors it's funny because in other
contexts the pandemic isn't serious so
when it's convenient for rand paul to
say
masks
closures
guidelines restrictions this isn't
nearly serious enough and now he's
saying
this is so serious dr fauci that you're
lying to us well now you're getting into
something if the point that you are
making
is that the
the grant that was funded as a sub award
from ecohealth to wuhan created sauce
kovi 2.
that's where you are getting
okay so again it's just endless with
rand paul
we've talked about the gain of function
stuff a number of times already at the
end of the day you could say this could
just come down to a sort of semantic
disagreement between entities in terms
of definitions of gain of function
but the obsession of rand paul is what
just cannot be understood here let's
look at a little more and here's where
fauci says if anybody here is lying it's
you rand paul
for four million people dying around the
world from a pandemic and let's let's
send dr i have to well now you're
getting into something if the point that
you are making is that the
the grant and there's a little bit of
overlap here for which i apologize
funded as a sub award from eco health to
wuhan created sauce kovi 2.
that's where you are getting let me
finish we don't know
wait a minute it didn't come in the lab
but all the evidence is pointing that it
came from the lab and there will be
responsibility for those who funded the
lab including yourself i totally rand
paul is blaming dr fouchy for the
pandemic
the witness to i totally resent the lie
that you are now propagating senator
because if you look at the viruses
that were used in the experiments
that were given in the annual reports
that were published in the literature
it is molecularly impossible no one's
saying that it is caused it is
those virus caused the pandemic what
we're alleging is that gain of function
research was going on in that lab and
nih funded it that is get away from it
it meets your definition and you are
obfuscating the truth i'm not
obfuscating the truth you're the one
expired but i will allow the witness to
let me just finish i want everyone to
understand that if you look at those
viruses and that's judged by qualified
virologists and evolutionary biologists
those viruses are molecularly impossible
pause the pandemic
we're saying they are gain of function
viruses because there were animal
viruses that became more transmissible
and human and you funded it and you
admit the truth and you implying paul
your time has expired and i will allow
witnesses who come before this committee
to respond
and you are implying
that what we did was responsible for the
deaths of individual
i totally resent that and if anybody is
lying here senator it is you so this is
just
never ending never ending and the you
know
the
the world is looking
at how a doctor who has devoted his life
to trying to prevent pandemics and
communicable disease infectious disease
has become you know if not enemy number
one
uh uh uh sort of co-enemy number one
to a particular political contingent in
the united states it's humiliating and
it's embarrassing and do not expect this
to stop anytime soon if you want to
see more about the gain of function
distinctions check out our previous clip
about this just go to our youtube
channel search for anthony fauci rand
paul and you will find uh at least one
maybe even a couple of clips about it i
want to go next to the fear-mongering
around so-called vaccine passports
because something incredible has been
taking place at fox news
fox news hosts have been slamming the
possibility as well as the use of
so-called vaccine passports which
basically means proving you've been
vaccinated in certain situations in
order to be allowed to do something or
to go somewhere fox hosts have been
fear-mongering around so-called vaccine
passports for months now
without mentioning that fox news is
using a vaccine passport
we're going to look at the details
momentarily but if you want to seriously
criticize the use of such vaccine
passports
have the gall to say my own employer is
doing it right now
but they won't tell you that there's a
very good write-up about this in rolling
stone by peter wade called fox rails
against vaccine passports
uses vaccine passports explaining that
tucker carlson and other hosts have
railed on air against the idea of
so-called vaccine passports but never
told their audience that fox uses one of
its own
hypocrisy spreading lies and
fear-mongering are well-known staples at
fox but monday's news about how fox
corporation has already implemented a
vaccine passport type program for its
own employees that is similar to what
hosts tucker carlson and laura ingraham
have loudly railed against is a window
into how little they actually care about
the well-being of people who watch their
shows
businesses that require employees to
provide proof of vaccination commonly
referred to as a vaccine passport have
been slammed frequently on the network
tucker has called the idea the medical
equivalent of jim crow segregationist
laws another host compared the
requirements to communist east germany
and laura ingraham has falsely claimed
that such programs are akin to tracking
mechanisms but not one host has told
their audience about fox clearpass which
works for fox employees the exact same
way
most vaccine passport systems do in
other businesses listen to this
an internal fox email first reported by
ryan grimm and also obtained by rolling
stone
spells out how fox employees were
instructed how to enter their
vaccination information into the
company's passport program called fox
clearpass
in order to avoid fox's mandated
requirements to social distance and wear
masks while at work
sent on june 22 to all fox news staff
the email outlines how vaccinated staff
can prove their vaccinated status by
entering info into a workday human
resources system employees who prove
vaccination can get a fox clear pass
which allows them to bypass screening
procedures they have a vaccine passport
at fox news
and laura and tucker and others have
railed against this without mentioning
my own employer has it the details are
fully vaccinated individuals who have
entered their vaccination info into
workday are not required to wear a mask
or socially distance while at work let
me remind you
of all of these instances of
fear-mongering around exactly
this type of vaccine passport this is a
nice little compilation from media
matters take a listen to this left is
going to begin the push for vaccine
mandates oh no and vaccine passports
vaccine passports oh yay plans for a
vaccine passport this vaccine passport
the vaccine passport vaccine passport
there's going to be growing pressure
across all of corporate america to force
proof of vaccination status whoa you
mean like by fox news right laura
movement for everything just like no
mask no entry
no vaccination no entry vaccinated only
sections so vaccination segregation the
very same people literally the very same
who just the other day told us that
segregation was immoral are now
enforcing segregation like my employer
only making the unvaccinated wear masks
at turning point usa we are going to
give it everything we have to make sure
that students are not going to have to
live in a medical apartheid because they
don't want to get the vaccine
medical jim crow has come to america if
we still had water fountains the
unvaccinated would have separate ones
right even to the bullies on this
vaccine passport issue the ongoing mass
mandate school restrictions
and they'll never stop chipping away at
your liberty and your privacy and by the
way just so you know as proof if you
want to get a job you'll need your
vaccine papers and i even need to show
them in order to not wear a mask here if
you're worried about being forced to
show your papers for travel well you
should be that we're on the verge of
east german style show me your papers
all right so you
you guys get the point
the hypocrisy guys the hypocrisy and
so there's actually a couple of
hypocrisies and it's important to
understand all of them
and i don't think that the anti-vaccine
right understands them or would uh
believe them if they were confronted
with them number one
the people warning you about the vaccine
passports are saying nothing about the
fact that they work at a place with
vaccine passports that's number one but
maybe even more importantly more
hypocritically more cartoonishly
dystopian
is that the very people warning you
about vaccines
many of them have been vaccinated but
refuse to say that publicly
uh and i don't know which is the bigger
hypocrisy i don't know which is the
bigger danger we're gonna have more on
this on the david pakman show instagram
make sure you're following us there at
david pakman show coming up after this
uh i won't even tell you what it is
because it's so horrifying we'll just
talk about it in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
so there's a segment from the sean
hannity fox news program from the other
day that was meant to prop up this idea
of joe biden's not with it joe biden's
having a cognitive issue joe biden can't
think joe biden's brain is imminently
going to fall out of his head or
whatever the case may be
and the clip is just stunning for its
lack of
even like any self-awareness about the
fact that there were real questions
about donald trump's cognitive struggles
throughout his presidency so let's look
at the first clip to begin with this is
sean hannity and kaylee mcinanni saying
can you even imagine if there were
questions about for example trump's
cognitive state and it's like
there were do you not remember kaylee
look at this can you imagine kaylee if
this was donald trump's record or donald
trump was struggling cognitively like
this what would it be like
i can't imagine i i mean look i i was at
the podium when i was asked over and
over again about his trips to walter
reed and they were routine visits that
he took but they were convinced
something sinister something must have
been wrong with the president he must
have been covering something up
okay so
do you guys remember the fact that
donald trump was constantly acting
bizarrely and there were never any
explanations given and none of it made
any sense like these folks seem to have
missed trump's entire presidency uh just
a couple of examples i mean just just as
a reminder look at a few things hear
trump not only referring to the 1917
pandemic which didn't exist it was 1918
but says that it ended the second world
war which was of course more than a
decade later in 1917 they say right the
the great the great pandemic certainly
was a terrible thing where they lost
anywhere from 50 to 100 million people
probably ended the second world war all
the soldiers were sick
uh it was a that was a terrible now i
guess he meant the first world war and
1918
which it's not actually true that the
1918 flu ended the for just completely
confused and think if joe biden said
that what would you be seeing on fox
news trump of course talking about the
oranges the citrus fruit of an
investigation really wanting to get down
to the rind of things we could say
and looking confused realizing my my
brain's not connecting properly with my
mouth here they now go and take a look
at the oranges the oranges of the
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation that's weird that's weird
and never an explanation and kaylee
pretending like the only real questions
are about joe biden the endless physical
shoulder spasms simultaneous to like a
mental catch on a word constantly
happening
regularly there were people seeking a
medical explanation for this here's just
one example of that
and let me begin by wishing you a
beautiful look do you remember this do
you remember
they were trying to take christmas he
sort of covers it in a way where you
don't necessarily
pay more attention to it unless you're
aware of the fact that that happens all
the time
never an explanation for why that
happened regularly there was also this
incident and
i'll just
we'll show some video as i describe it
there's this strange incident where
donald trump came down off of air force
one
and his vehicle parked
right at the bottom of the steps and
donald trump famously just kind of
wandering off and having to be brought
back his vehicle is always right there
secret service everybody waiting for him
to get in and trump just wanders away
and people start wondering what what is
happening here eventually someone comes
up to trump and says yeah the car is
right there the car was right at the
bottom of the stairs like it always is
every single time and donald trump
brought back to that vehicle and
we're not going to belabor this but just
to
remind you guys ima you know
sean hannity and kaylee say imagine if
trump had done the stuff biden is doing
imagine what right-wing media would have
looked like if biden was doing half the
trump stuff trump did they did an entire
event about an executive order
and trump left without signing it and
then mike pence sort of like pretended
like the plan all along was to sign it
in private even though they had a whole
desk set up for trump trump to sign it
in public remember this were you trying
to tell the justice department to grant
immunity to michael flynn
were you trying to do that mr president
is that your intention mr president sir
thank you mr president was that your
intention were you trying to tell the
trump just wandering away and then pence
reminding him you kind of didn't sign
the thing that we were here to sign and
then just two last ones very quickly
trump referring uh to apple ceo tim cook
as tim apple
country we appreciate it very much tim
apple tim apple and then also uh
referring to marilyn hewson the ceo of
lockheed as marilyn lockheed
and we have some of our great business
leaders
and leaders period right behind me uh i
may ask marilyn lockheed
the
leading
yeah women's business
executive okay so you guys get the point
and so the he the the real story here is
when you see these segments on fox news
where they say something like imagine if
trump had ever done the things joe biden
has done and then you look at what joe
biden's done and it's like oh yeah joe
biden has a stutter and he's nearly 80.
and he's clearly slowed down from like
when he ran circles around paul ryan
however many years ago it was they said
trump never had anything like this no no
no no it's quite the opposite and in
fact she and hannity and everybody else
was running interference all along when
that was the case just pathetic
hypocrisy and double standards hey we
have the political media equivalent
of kim jong-un and hitler having a baby
the my pillow ceo mike lindell
is now supporting
alex jones infowars conspiracy show
mike lindell's mike pillow is now
running ads on infowars he's offering an
alex jones promo code and alex jones
talked about
pillows and sheets and all these
different things it's absolutely wild
but
but
this is something the right has that the
left doesn't and the right is better off
for it now i'll explain what i mean by
that in a moment if you're not familiar
with mike lindell and or alex jones alex
jones is a major conspiracy theorist uh
infowars is his platform his channel he
has been banned from youtube he's been
banned from a bunch of different
platforms for regularly peddling all
sorts of conspiracy theories including
specific ones that are so specific about
individuals
that it has ruined some people's lives
it has ruined people's lives when they
become the the target or the focus
um of the ire of alex jones audience
alex jones has sometimes had to
apologize there have been lawsuits etc
he's been kicked off a bunch of
platforms similarly mike lindell almost
like a match made in heaven i don't know
or hell depending on your perspective
mike lindell also pushing all sorts of
conspiracy theories claiming that he has
found of voting machines which he has in
his possession which prove that even
california was actually won by donald
trump he's insisted trump would be
reinstated in you know march and then
may and then most recently august
although he might be off by a month it
might actually be september so now they
are together
here is alex jones promoting
it's so pathetic various sheets and
pillows and even towels if you can
imagine you've got your amazing towel
pack it's 109
for 39.95 with promo code alex you're
barely bringing any money there people
should purchase it there to fund what
you're doing they should help buy it 109
but 39.95
i'm not that's a huge discount by you
and i'm told all other products
up to 66 percent off with promo code
alex so promo code
a-l-e-x mypillow.com and i'm just super
excited to tell my listeners to go
support you and get great products
because if they don't fund this war
effort if they don't back us up and pray
for us and spread the word and support
us financially the globalists are going
to win so uh again people got to put
fuel in your tank you are taking the
globalist on toe to toe and if we don't
energize you well then we deserve to
lose so so tell folks about these these
amazing towels i know you want to do
this today but a couple weeks ago you
said this to me
tell us about the towels the sheets all
the products
well the towels are the best house in
history they actually dry you they don't
they don't feel like the ones the doors
like all lotion they work these are the
towels you've seen on tv the best towels
ever isn't that just an incredible deal
guys and you can tell alex jones
really loves these products but he also
points out
you know you've got to buy this stuff
to support the fight against the
globalists it's a political thing the
towels and the sheets are really
shocking i mean doctors have looked at
these and they just can't believe what
these towels are able to do but it's not
just that the towels are great there's a
political reason that you have to buy
them and that is to fight
globalists now this is the very same
mike lindell
uh who when appearing as a guest said he
thinks trump actually won california not
joe biden trump's going to be reinstated
again by some mechanism that is unknown
to us and to anybody else who
understands how elections work and how
the constitution works and just consider
the sort of groups that have been
brought together under the delusions of
trumpism people who would normally never
want to be around each other even for a
second at the top level as i've said
before
trump's followers are overwhelmingly the
people that trump uh was disgusted by
most of his life as a rich new yorker
trump grew up in a bubble
in which
you know uh the
the farmers who go to his rallies in
iowa
uh the boaters with the little outboard
motors who boated to his rally when he
did one who knows where in florida
during these are people trump wanted to
isolate and insulate himself from his
entire life that match is already weird
but you know even like the militia gun
types
and then the big city conspiracy
theorists who never would own a gun and
then the anti-vaxxed
uh nuttery people all over the place
people that have been brought together
in some sense
by
the campaign and the political presence
of donald trump and mike lindell and
mike pillow now with mike my pillow not
mike pillow are now brought together uh
sponsoring fox news and tucker carlson
for a long time sponsoring steve
bannon's one america or you know steve
bannon's war room and one america news
and right side broadcasting all this
stuff and then now also alex jones and
infowars lindell is uh really has bought
his way into being one of the most
influential anti-vaccine conspiracy
theorists out there he's called the
vaccines the mark of the beast on
multiple occasions and a guy continuing
to foment the election lies and
conspiracy theories and then on the
other hand alex jones uh infamous 911
truther so-called
sandy hook conspiracy theorist has
promoted conspiracy theories i think
about chobani yogurt at one point um and
alex jones conspiracy theories go from
just very stupid to very very dangerous
and he's carried out harassment
campaigns etc so they are mostly getting
away with this stuff without
consequences
yes alex jones has had to apologize a
couple of times his lawyers have had to
go to court and do that pathetic thing
where they say listen
he's an entertainer much like tucker
carlson and fox news lawyers have said
about tucker he's using hyperbole and
exaggeration you don't this isn't news
in in the literal sense uh alex jones
lawyers have had to do the same thing
um but big picture there have not been
real consequences mike lindell has
become very wealthy with this stuff uh
alex jones has become relatively wealthy
although we don't know exactly what the
financial situation is right now because
of all of the legal trouble uh there is
no real equivalent to this on the left
and when i say that i mean two things
there's no real equivalent to this on
the left from the standpoint of the
level of unhinged nuttery that is this
prominent there's conspiracy theories on
the left there's no doubt they don't
become prominent like this
but
they also benefit on the right because
having funders like mike lindell that
will just throw money at everything
they'll throw money at bannon they'll
throw money at whoever you know my uh
all these people alex jones
this gives them a leg up it does and
alex jones thanks to his supplement
sales as well as now being funded by my
pillow
is able to continue producing the
propaganda
um
whereas in other circumstances he might
really be having trouble by virtue of
having lost the youtube platform etc so
good for them and i say that cynically
it gives them a leg up and that's why
you continue to see a lot of this stuff
spread
let me know your thoughts about that big
funding difference that the left just
doesn't have it we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show so i didn't cover this yesterday
but more has happened and i do want to
say a little bit about it a radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
green a major conspiracy theorist and
node of disinformation that's i know d e
my friends um
i know i'll get emails about that one uh
she was suspended from twitter for 12
hours now you can interpret that as
twitter is finally expanding its reach
in terms of really clamping down on the
disinformation and misinformation or you
could see it as 12 hours is completely
meaningless it's symbolic and it merely
provided marjorie taylor green with the
opportunity to weaponize the ban and
continue perpetuating conspiracy
theories including about social media
vendettas against her which do you think
it was
mostly the second mostly the second i
mean 12 hours
let's look at what we know about it new
york times writing twitter suspends
marjorie taylor green for posting
coveted misinformation
the republican lawmaker from georgia
cannot tweet for 12 hours after the
white house criticized social media
sites for amplifying vaccine lies
twitter said on monday it was suspending
green
for 12 hours after she posted messages
that violated its policy against sharing
misleading information about the
coronavirus
green of georgia has been an outspoken
opponent of vaccines and masks as tools
to curb the pandemic in tweets on sunday
and monday she argued that covid19 was
not dangerous from four people unless
they were obese or over age 65 and said
vaccines should not be required now of
course they're not from the standpoint
of any kind of government mandate there
are private businesses and institutions
which as an
anti-regulation republican she certainly
should respect their ability to say
here's who we want to do business with
or don't or here are the requirements to
work here as long as they don't violate
the law
the article goes on to say with cases of
the virus on the rise
and the highly contagious delta variant
accounting for more than half of new
infections
in the u.s federal health officials say
this month in miss green's home state
georgia new cases have increased 193
percent in the past two weeks twitter
said green's tweets were misinformation
and barred her until tuesday quote we
took enforcement action on the account
mt green e for violations of the twitter
rules specifically the covet 19
misleading information policy
miss green said silicon valley companies
are working with the white house to
attack speech
free speech these big tech companies are
doing the bidding of the biden regime to
restrict our voices and prevent the
spread of a message that's not state
approved
twitter took action after biden called
on social media companies to do more to
combat the spread of vaccine
misinformation on their platform biden
said sites like facebook are killing
people
so
you know the problem here is
of course marjorie taylor green is
spreading dangerous covet and vaccine
disinformation on twitter there's no
doubt whatsoever there's no doubt it
violates twitter's terms of service the
issue i have is what are we really doing
by doing this for 12 hours now if it's
this is the first time it's 12 hours and
next time it'll be a week and next time
it'll be a full suspension
okay i could be convinced that taking a
lighter touch now
maybe makes some sense but the problem
is that this is all a closed loop
they claim that social media is
censoring them
they then post vaccine conspiracies that
are dangerous this disinformation so
they get banned and then they say see i
told you so i told you that they're
censoring us i told you that they're
banning us it's it's doxastic closure
that's a term i used before it's a
logical closure another way to say it is
that these are self-fulfilling beliefs
it's a win-win in some sense for
marjorie taylor greene either she gets
to keep peddling disinformation on
twitter
or
she gets banned and then says i'm a
martyr
they've canceled me i'm the most
cancelled woman or whatever the case so
it ends up kind of being a gift i think
it's better to ban her in a serious way
if she's going to be spreading the
disinformation which she is which
violates twitter policy and as soon as
she got back on twitter because it was
only a 12-hour ban
she first likened the suspension to
communist china tweeting american social
media company twitter banned me for 12
hours censoring me violating my freedom
of speech
that's of course not true twitter's a
private company they can enforce terms
of service she said you know who else
silences sensors and bans people they
don't like and want heard
communist china
communism is not good
save america stop communism you know who
else breathes oxygen
hitler right i mean that's essentially
what this is
then tweeting fouchy lied people died
fire fouchy
then tweeting a picture of herself doing
a press conference which we'll talk
about momentarily
captioning it communist style twitter
ban press conference happening now
and then tweeting sports illustrated
feats featured a trans biological male
and an elite female tennis player this
year
do sports illustrated see the irony
in promoting a trans
and a female athlete when biological men
are now being allowed to defeat women in
women's sports
promoting men defeating women is woke
so immediately
going into
more anti-science stuff the fire fouchy
attack fouchy thing is a big
anti-science movement now we're going to
talk more about that tomorrow we talked
about it earlier today
doing anti-trans stuff she immediately
should be banned again if twitter
actually wants us to believe that she's
taking this seriously
next i want to talk about
this press conference that she held
which is just completely out of this
world
so upon her return
from her 12-hour twitter ban radical
republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor-greene announced she's holding a
press conference in her office the press
conference was primarily
highlighted by terrible audio where you
can barely hear the people asking the
questions and you can barely hear
marjorie taylor green we've amped up the
audio level so that you hopefully will
be able to hear it and this first
question goes right to
i don't know how these right-wingers get
fixated on bogus talking points
that make no sense but they do
and marjorie taylor-green is a big
proponent of the hipaa
bogus vaccine talking point all right so
let's listen to this one first aaron
navarro cbs news uh whip scales said
today he got vaccinated siding this
delta varying that's going around and
said he's confident that it's safe and
effective two questions have you
yourself gotten vaccinated and do you
disagree with the republican whip well
your your first question is a violation
of my hipaa rights you see with hipaa
rights we don't have to reveal our
medical records and that also involves
our vaccine records so that is a
complete and total lie
this has been repeated sean hannity has
said it
marjorie taylor green has said it a
bunch of times a journalist asking a
public figure who is talking about the
merits of vaccination
is not a violation of hipaa rights hipaa
stipulates how information that is held
by health care and health care insurance
companies has to be protected from fraud
and theft it relates to the digital
transmission of such information
and uh it relates to
um
those entities exclusively it has
nothing to do with media questions it it
just has nothing to do with it when you
go into a doctor's office and you're
given something that's their privacy
policy and how they protect your data
and who they will share data that's
governed by hipaa
when you are a congresswoman who lies
about vaccines
and a journalist says are you vaccinated
the question doesn't violate anything
related to hipaa she's not forced to
answer she didn't by the way and it's
genuinely stunning that i mean i know
stupid talking points catch on this is a
really really stupid talking point and i
tweeted about this last night saying
could anybody tell her that hippa
relates to medical providers and privacy
not journalists asking public figures
questions
one common reaction was basically david
she's been vaccinated
but she wants to give certain people who
follow her the idea that she hasn't
because that's what a lot of her whole
indignant perspective and approach
is predicated on the idea that she's
opposing the vaccine and putting her
money where her mouth is they're putting
her health where her mouth is when in
reality she's been vaccinated maybe
that's the case i don't know
maybe she has been vaccinated but if
you're telling everyone to be skeptical
of the vaccine
it's relevant
and completely appropriate for
journalists to say
have you been vaccinated now let's
continue just a couple other disgusting
moments from this thing
she was uh she as in her statement she
said something about
if you're not obese and you're not over
65
you're not gonna die so therefore you
don't need to be vaccinated and someone
points out to her skinny people and kids
have also died and she just laughs it's
dangerous do you feel any responsibility
for keeping
people in georgia safe you know there
are children
skinny people
who have died of the coronavirus do you
feel any responsibility
to yeah right yeah um you know what i
think people's responsibility is their
own so this is just continued disgusting
stuff
um i mentioned this when we talked about
when joe rogan said a couple months ago
young people don't need to get
vaccinated there's no reason for young
people to get vaccinated i'm
paraphrasing
and he said you know if you eat a good
diet and you exercise
i have looked and have still found no
study that suggests diet and exercise
makes you uh less
susceptible to the virus in terms of an
infection which you may then spread
certainly underlying health makes you
less likely to have a serious case
that's true but we live in a society
folks and this stuff from marjory taylor
green is just disgusting one last moment
a marjorie taylor green
lashed out at marie newman in a
transphobic rant marie newman is a
congressional candidate newman's
daughter is transgender newman has
talked about how
the lack of support for trans people and
trans youth influenced her running for
office
and here's marjorie taylor green in a
transphobic
newman just called you a deeply broken
person and hoped that you would get some
help do you have any response to this
i think
my colleague democrat marie newman that
is across the hall for me
should probably get some help herself
because she's the one that attacked me
on a on a video by planting a flag out
there in the hallway but starting on my
nameplate you see she started that you
do understand that right she started it
guys she started by a video on my name
plate and then it pans to her where in a
militant fashion she plants a flag
but you know and then she talks about
her um biological son who she calls her
daughter
and she talks about one and of course i
hope you guys know when
using this phraseology of
her son who she calls her daughter which
completely delegitimizes every aspect of
transgender individuals it's just marie
newman is just calling something a
different name than it actually should
be called right
it's completely dehumanizing she wants
her son to be able to go in women's
bathrooms and have all the same rights
as women but you know what i have
daughters too
and i don't want men in my daughter's
bathroom so just a completely disgusting
bathroom a transphobic bathroom rant
from marjory taylor green
really truly genuinely a despicable
person if she gets re-elected and she's
she's presumably going to run
we are really going to have to concede
that this virus of trumpism is probably
going to be here to stay for some
significant period of time
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p here's a caller
who wants more interviews with loony
people do you agree with them take a
listen
hey david this is devin from rhode
island yeah i was wondering if you would
go back to interviewing the loonies
you know all the crazy people and
delusional people bad faith actors
because
watching you handle professionally
handle these people
really helps us normal people who aren't
naturally gifted at it who might blow up
emotionally who don't know how to
respond to the faulty logic
watching you
interact and
and question them and then listen to
their answer and take apart their answer
or or even give them credit when you
know they are right
watching you do that really helps us uh
maybe do a poll and see what other
people think yeah i mean
i really appreciate the kind words the
reason we've gotten away from it is
sometimes the loony people are also
really annoying to schedule interviews
with like as as loony as they are on
camera they're just as loony in the
management of their personal calendar
and to be perfectly frank i got a little
bored with it because it's like yeah
how
most of us know that these people exist
and i find that it's better
to critique their views without them
right there screaming and going nuts
it's sometimes much more productive that
way but i'm open to doing more of the
looney interviews if people are really
interested in that it just i was
starting to get a little bored with it
and my sense was the audience maybe
didn't care for it that much but i'm
certainly willing to look at that on
today's bonus show
states that ended federal unemployment
benefits saw no clear job gains despite
what right-wingers were claiming would
happen
california is going to launch the
nation's largest free student lunch
program
but how can they afford it with their
huge budget surplus that's exactly how
and a u.s judge has upheld indiana
university's vaccine requirement which
applies in the fall to students faculty
and staff
we will talk about why and we will talk
about what we are likely to see in other
challenges against college vaccine
requirements all of that
and even more on today's bonus show sign
up at joinpackman.com we will see you
there or tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman